the number of UK deaths has been rising
at a faster rate than both Italy and
China the same stage of their outbreak
both of which experienced unsustainable
pressure on their health services as we
know some regions are recording more
deaths than others as of sassily
in London one in every 100,000 people
have died all that's ten per million the
West Midlands has five point four per 1
million followed by the southeast which
has a ratio of four point seven but
within those regions NHS capacity and
the age of the population varies widely
researchers at Oxford University have
looked at both to identify the areas
that could come under most pressure from
Kovac 19 based on recently published
infection rates these so called hospital
deserts include Paris Northumberland
Rutland Suffolk and V Isle of Wight
where hospitals could easily become
overwhelmed the research suggests some
regions can cope with a higher rate of
infection than others for example London
the worst affected region so far can
cope with an infection rate of 4.7
percent of its population compared to
Cornwall at only one point five percent
but London's age profile varies widely
from borough to borough Harrow for
example has an older population and
Norfolk Park Hospital declared a
critical incident on March the 19th
after running out of intensive care beds
due to coronavirus admissions whereas
the London borough of newham has a
comparatively younger population it
might expect fewer hospital admissions
with the outbreak in the UK currently
around two weeks behind Italy the
government will be asking itself what it
can do to prevent our health system
being overwhelmed in a similar way